"Повний лузер, так сумно", -
можна було прочитати на будівлі посольства США в Берліні
після того, як стало відомо про вихід США з Паризької кліматичної угоди.
Так на рішення Дональда Трампа
відреагували екологічні активісти.
Політики висловлюються стриманіше.
"Рішення США вийти з Паризької угоди
вкрай сумне.
І це я сказала ще дуже стримано.
Угода залишається наріжним каменем
співпраці країн світу.
Вона необхідна для досягнення цілей ООН
у сфері сталого розвитку до 2030 року".
Німеччина, Франція та Італія оприлюднили спільну заяву,
в якій висловили впевненість в тому,
що Паризька хартія щодо клімату -
всупереч бажанню Дональда Трампа -
не може бути переглянута.
"Це рішення нас дуже засмутило. Але воно не стало для нас несподіванкою.
Ми впевнені в тому, що винесемо, цей, поза сумнівом, важкий удар".
Але, мабуть, з найбільш емоційною промовою
виступив президент Франції Еммануель Макрон.
"Я закликаю вас зберігати рішучість.
У нас все вийде, тому що ми
переконані в необхідності кліматичної угоди.
Тому що де б ми не жили, ким би ми не були,
ми всі поділяємо цю відповідальність. Зробимо нашу планету знову великою!"
З подачі президента Франції
хештег #MakeOurPlanetGreatAgain  розлетівся по всьому Твіттеру.
У німецькій же пресі поруч з розчаруванням і обуренням чутні й оптимістичні голоси.
"Ниття не допоможе.
Виведення Дональдом Трампом США з кліматичної угоди -
це  визнання Сполученими Штатами свого політичного та морального банкрутства.
Хороша новина: далі все залежить лише від нас,
а не від Вашингтона.
На сайті тижневика "Цайт" читаємо:
"Париж живе.
США порушує свою обіцянку. Це важкий удар.
Але те, що інші країни об’єднуються задля захисту клімату, вселяє надію".
Судячи з усього,
заява Трампа про вихід США з кліматичної угоди  згуртувала Європу.